you been rolling this on time
stairs that last too long awkward slips
and jokes lost in translation made for a
whole lot of actors on the no way home
set blushing from embarrassment the
perfection we see on screen doesn't look
so slick behind the scenes we're
checking out 15 scenes that left
spider-man actors feeling very awkward
[Music]
[Applause]
number one
look into my spidey eyes just try not to
laugh while doing it well it's easier
said than done one of the most awkward
moments for toby and andrew to film
together involved this very long deep
and intense stare which as we can see
from behind the scenes was a day filled
with way more laughter than anything
toby called it for what it was
explaining
it is weird staring at you for that long
the actors managed to hit their marks
but every single time they were rolling
it was just worsening how embarrassing
the whole ordeal was
number
two tom holland makes for a great
superhero but helping his taller
co-stars can be tricky and i'm the
superhero i'm supposed to look cool the
fact that tom's mj zendaya is taller
than him made this particular scene an
embarrassing challenge he's supposed to
gently you know rest mj on the bridge
and walk away from her but that wasn't
gonna happen because of just how
significant their height difference is i
would land before him my feet obviously
hit the ground before he does so zendaya
did what zendaya does best she stepped
up to the plate and did what tom
unfortunately couldn't and then i would
sort of land like this and my feet would
swing from underneath me and then she
would catch me
luckily for tom he got to have plenty of
cool looking moments throughout the rest
of the movie
number three
who says he can't go home there was a
good a good two-year period where
it was over for me having accepted his
mcu time was over charlie cox was very
surprised to have gotten the call from
kevin feige actually making sure the
offer wasn't a joke luckily marvel's
people got in touch with his people and
cox joined the no way home set and
nerves came along with it especially
when john watts asked the performer to
insert a significant pause in the scene
one that really worried cox he explained
i was a bit embarrassed like are you
sure i was going with the flow but
thinking i hope it's not a letdown and
when he saw the movie in a theater his
worst fear came true i must have been
one of the only movie theaters in
america that had was
dead silence fortunately he was assured
by friends and family that all the other
screenings they went to had really
positive receptions for the daredevil
actor being on screen
number four
the spidey suit can cause problems for
more than just the person wearing it
holland let something slip and it didn't
go unnoticed it all started with a stunt
that as a as a stunt is one of the
most lame looking off-camera stunts to
be fair these actors were really all up
in each other's business you were like
sort of sitting on my lap and then jacob
was hugging both of us and in the midst
of all that action holland had an
embarrassing slip yeah i farted on me
unfortunately yeah it's tough the suit's
tight the harness squeezes even though
there wasn't much going on zendaya was
close enough to know what had happened
without a doubt i felt the rattle sorry
about that number five
sometimes things get a bit lost in
translation
holland was in over his head his
britishness coming through when he
struggled to get a joke one of his
co-stars made on set there's a line
where i say i think i can fix you alfred
molina as doc ock had a stellar comeback
about being fixed like a dog but it just
caused confusion and embarrassment for
holland especially when molina started
making snipping motions with his hands
and i kept responding with like no why
would you fix a dog the term used for
neutering a pet isn't the same in
england so it was really a case of
cultural differences still it made for
quite an embarrassing shoot for holland
so i was very confused every time he
said it i was like why does he keep
ad-libbing this line about
fixing dogs number six
except this was kind of improv
perfection in reality andrew garfield
was sentimental as could be on set and
who could blame him but at one point
that emotion slipped out in the middle
of a scene when he first said wait wait
wait i love you guys
did it land not so much as the others
reacted oh so casually leaving garfield
with his heart on his sleeve for
everyone on set to see fortunately the
boys all had a good laugh about it
corpsing multiple times while trying to
nail the take anyway given the fact that
the scene around them is meant to be
chaotic but in reality the full scene
was taking place in front of a blue
screen well it just makes it all that
much more awkward
number seven
he might be nimble but he ain't graceful
spidey tom was all confidence racing
through the set only to land on his
backside and take down a giant set piece
with him as if everything wasn't chaotic
enough the actor had to go and add more
work for the set designer and put a
delay in shooting all because of one
little goof you can bet he was trying to
keep his frantic action a bit more
controlled after that incident
number eight
who is the most villainous villain the
one who put everyone on edge while
filming was the one and only willem
dafoe bringing us the green goblin like
we've never seen him before zendaya
explained that dafoe gave loads of
actors on set a real fright the filming
of his epic battle with tom was so much
more embarrassing for all those cast and
crew members watching and really being
terrified by defoe's convincing
performance
his portrayal may have embarrassed those
frightened onlookers on set but it made
his terror in the movie that much better
number nine
you gotta pay a price to look this cool
the reality is sometimes the spider-man
actors don't look cool at all zendaya
caught tom on set in his mask once but
without the helmet portion and let's
just say it looks far from cool in this
state it just kind of collapses on
itself so it looks really
interesting to say the least you also
really are able to see how
strange my head shape is
yeah on top of that holland was always a
bit embarrassed by the fact that the
suit makes you look small in all the
areas you don't want to look small for
andrew garfield and toby maguire who
were putting the suit on again after
years while the intimidation and
embarrassment of suiting up again was
real
it was a really
scary thing to attempt yeah especially
just the costume number 10.
do shoes in the mcu have snow grips we
doubt it based on this footage of actors
on set very clearly struggling with the
addition of snow those boots are not
made for winter walking that's for sure
cumberbatch had some particularly
embarrassing slips we've never seen
doctor strange looking this clumsy
before and tom has definitely had
smoother moments as well
number 11
without cgi some things just don't work
to accomplish what gets filmed
oftentimes the actors will have to
resort to awkward setups but this was
one that took the embarrassment cake
it's like one day they will be something
but right now it's just two guys and
blue suits yes tom and zendaya were
fleeing as two men in full blue trailed
after them hilarious yes but also very
awkward to make matters worse that is
also like he's called colin he's in a
blue suit it's all good though colin in
the blue suit we appreciate you
number 12
the throwback that haunts him toby
maguire infamously injured his back to
the point that he almost wasn't able to
do a second film which in fact was
actually part of a plan to get a bigger
paycheck as punishment the team for that
movie called him out on screen with back
pain jokes that were written into the
script who could resist the chance to
whip out that old chestnut again
toby was once again paying the price for
the stunt he pulled all those years ago
number 13.
okay but just how amazing is he
well we think the most
everyone loves a throwback to their past
and just in case anyone forgot andrew
garfield is the amazing spider-man
maguire didn't let him forget it in no
way home whipping out the joke and
managing to somehow film this scene
without corpsing completely garfield
took it all in stride like the class act
he is
number 14
spider-man vs spider a tale as old as
time if tom holland got scared of a
spider web on set does that mean he
technically scared himself either way
the fact that the spider-man was so
thrown by a spiderweb in the middle of
filming his plea that could help him and
his friends get a shot at going to
school together well it was an
embarrassing look to say the least
number 15.
these spideys are staying tight-lipped
we have to know
which spider-man is sporting a padded
butt the rumors have been pointing
heavily towards toby maguire but these
spideys are bros for life and all of
them have been sure to not throw their
spidey brothers under the bus okay well
maybe except for tom who let the little
details slip in the first place
spider-man spider-man does whatever a
spider can unless there is a web
involved if you're tom embarrassing
hilarious and just another reason to
appreciate no way home which of these
embarrassing scenes was your favorite